today it was announced that jager the
developer behind spec ops the line is no
longer working on Dead Island 2 Dead
Island publisher Deep Silver said in a
statement with Dead Island 2 deep silver
has always been dedicated to delivering
the sequel that dead island fans deserve
after careful consideration today we
announced the decision to part ways with
development partner jager we will
continue working towards bringing our
vision of Dead Island 2 to life and we
will share further information at a
later stage deep silver has not yet
announced which studio will be taking
over Dead Island 2 which was officially
announced during Sony's e3 press
conference last summer for playstation 4
and is also aiming to come out on xbox
one and pc the game is planned to
feature melee combat role playing game
elements and quote never-before-seen
handcrafted weapons according to Deep
Silver in Dead Island 2 which is powered
by the Unreal Engine 4 you'll visit
places like the Golden Gate Bridge in
San Francisco and Venice Beach also in
the works is multiplayer for up to eight
players in which you can quote cooperate
compete or simply coexist according to
Deep Silver will this change in
developer affect any and all of those
features planned for dead island to let
us know what you think in the comments
below and stay tuned to gamespot com /
news for all your news updates